so netflix released its new original
movie
gerald's game based off of stephen king
novel it is a
horror psychological thriller and it did
not disappoint
right now steven king movies are in it
just came out was a hit and now they're
coming full storm again it is back
but unlike it this was a little more of
a slow slow burn
and definitely more terrifying i would
think which i did not expect
it gets right to it though we see this
couple going to
their vacation home and gerald played by
bruce greenwood
can't get his boner to work he's taking
viagra he's getting his wife now to try
to do a rape fantasy
and he handcuffs carla gugino who plays
jesse
onto the bed and gerald has a heart
attack on top of her
and you're not even sure if he died or
not he thought maybe he's just playing
it up
to get her to get better in the mood
because she wasn't good at this role
play
and then she's like screaming help help
and she's like okay you're screwing with
me now i'm actually doing it right but
you're not really dead
and then that dog comes back in which i
thought was great because we see
this dog now starting to eat the meat of
the man who wasn't going to give him
food
and everything connects in this movie
really really well because at that point
in the movie i didn't know where it was
going to go how is it going to make
an hour and 40 minutes of this where
she's handcuffed to this bed
and there's a dog now just eating her
husband in front of her but they did a
really good job
she's basically losing her mind the
further you go here she's getting
dehydrated she's hallucinating
and she's falling asleep a lot and is
remembering a lot in her past and the
back story i thought here was the
strongest part of this movie
and just like in it we have another
creepy father story stephen king i don't
know why you're obsessed with this topic
please comment below if you know but it
was very effective again and it was hard
to watch
it really doesn't get more disturbing
than that growing up with your dad
basically jerking off behind you looking
at you and you're looking at a solar
eclipse
terrifying and not having other people
know about it in your life
very traumatic event that was a solid
meet to this story here
it was good because the movie put a
strong importance on that they focused
on it a lot and they gave it a lot of
time which i think was
super important so we knew where jesse
was coming from what her psychology was
like
and how it relate to the man she married
gerald gerald's a lot like her father
and she basically married
her dad like they always say a lot of
people marry who their parents are like
and you start to learn as it goes on how
much gerald was an [ __ ] too like her
dad
which he didn't really get right from
the start but it started getting there
especially he was doing the rape fantasy
and he was kind of being super forceful
on her
you got the hints and that's what her
she was used to in her life as a male
figure so it really touched upon well a
female
having bad male role model in her life
as a father
relating to the male role model she
looks for that she shouldn't even be
going after and she doesn't open up
about her problems and this is
the issue with not opening up about your
problems like this is this is all you
might you ever know
and that you think it's okay and it's
not but they really did a good job here
when she
is hallucinating and she sees her
husband
we now know is dead and she sees herself
herself the more rational side
and he's the more like negative side
like that's not gonna work this is not
gonna work
so she had to use her self-will to get
through this and that worked really well
with her being stuck to the bed
now comments i saw in this movie a lot
of people complain that oh come on she
should she could have got all those
handcuffs easily she could have twisted
off the bed posts
she could have shook the bed more let's
not nitpick
i mean to enjoy this movie kind of gotta
accept like okay this is the
circumstance it is very hard to get out
of handcuffs like that i mean you can
pick so many things in movies like this
it's not the point of it if that's
really bothering you then don't watch it
but come on just go with it a funny
thing is that phone is right there
she could have just probably been like
hey siri you know that function where
you can tell what to do for not even
touching the home button
so maybe siri could have saved a day in
this movie and maybe when serious
technology gets better in a couple years
you can't even make this movie so
good timing on that you still have to
plug it in the phone wasn't plugged in
so they paid attention to detail
because the hey siri function does not
work unless it's plugged in now if that
phone was plugged in
i might have stopped watching the movie
and been like she could have talked to
siri
to get 9-1-1 so good job continuity
director
the slender man figure dude she starts
to see and you're like is that real or
not
and then her husband's like oh look at
the footprint on the ground
that man's real that was terrifying and
that guy was scary and that was that
kind of fear where
i was watching this in my bed late at
night and i was like looking in my
closet and see if that guy was in there
that freaked me out
and then when she's driving and she's
like falling asleep at the wheel and
then she's
driving in a solar eclipse like highway
and then slenderman's in the back scene
looks in the mirror that was so scary
that freaked me
out it really delivered the horror kicks
and it was every scene with him was just
creepy and the shots i had with him all
the way down the hallway
really scary stuff and then it was even
scarier to find out he was real the
whole time
now a lot of people didn't like the end
where it revealed he was real
and i took away from him being that
symbolism of her taking away his what
her wedding wedding ring and
being that kind of monster that connects
to
her husband and her father but i like
that he was real i thought it was a nice
twist and it was a little different and
then you got to see him in the courtroom
it was a little goofy but
i like that she stood up to him and she
envisioned her father and her husband
when she saw the slender man
and she was like you're not so big after
all in person so i thought it had a good
message
wasn't the greatest ending but it fit
and it did tie everything together but
what really stood out for me was a
supporting cast here
and that's the daughter who played
jessie
really really good acting and her crying
in the scenes with the dad on the bed
and the dad was excellent too he played
that
anxious guilty but not really guilty
father that was just a creep
perfectly and my last credit's gonna go
with that dog dog killed it
we gotta get more props to dogs and
movies this was a good supporting dog
it really knew its cues kind of freaked
me out how good the dog was especially
the chemistry between the dog
i can't believe saying this especially
the chemistry between the dog and jessie
carla gugina wow
i was like how long did i have to
practice get that timing perfectly but
it was really well done
so hopefully the dog gets a uh
supporting
oscar actor nomination we can really
make history imagine bringing a dog on
stage at the oscars that would be pretty
cool and how hard was it to watch and
she was slipping her hand out of that
handcuff
oh they really pushed that guy on you
and when her skin flapped off
i was like i'm i'm usually not that
squeamish but that was that was
really really really really really hard
to watch not as good as it if we're
gonna compare it to the latest stephen
king movies
but it was more scary i thought and it
had a
really solid backstory so i'm gonna give
this movie a 7.5
wasn't amazing still felt a little slow
of parts it could have been a little
more exciting
i thought there was parts that dragged
and you felt a little bit of
you know rinse wash repeat with her
falling asleep talking to herself
then waking up and then falling back
asleep so it could have been a little
more
twist and turns maybe but overall solid
movie
7.5 especially for a streaming movie for
netflix hopefully the qualities movies
keep going up and this is a step in the
right direction
please comment below what you thought of
this movie i want to know everybody's
thoughts if you agree with me disagree
with me
anything i missed let me know what you
thought of the movie please subscribe
i review a bunch of movies tv shows i do
trailer reactions and celebrity
interviews
and keep coming back